hi there today we're looking at the
visual task adaptation benchmark by a
list of authors that's way too long to
read out all from Google brain so what
is this paper this paper cares about a
new benchmark that is abbreviated V tab
and V tab is a benchmark for a task
called visual task adaptation so a
benchmark the meaning of a benchmark is
it's kind of a a number that you achieve
and with a model and whoever has the
highest number is the best in at this
task right so the benchmark kind of
standardized is how you evaluate models
and the the model is here they do visual
task adaptation so what is visual task
adaptation so this is visual task
adaptation it's kind of illustrated in
this in this figure imagine you have a
bunch of what are called visual tasks
and the visual tasks and this is the
this right side here a visual task is
anything that can be solved from just
visual input so basically given a
picture or many pictures and you ask
kind of a question about it if that
question can be answered by just looking
at the picture then that's called a
visual task for example in this data set
you might be asked whether a picture
contains a dog or a cat in this data set
you might be asked to to outline where
the objects are so here the plane you
might be able to segment or you might be
able to point out where buildings are in
the images right here here
there's no building here so there's
there's a varieties of tasks that are
possible or in the bottom domain you
might be asked which one of the two red
dots here is closer to the observer in
3d space or you might be asked in this
picture please count the number of gray
boxes right
so that there's a bunch of all of these
countless visual tasks now that the
setting that the authors imagine here is
there are many of these visual tasks in
the world for which there isn't much
training data like imagine something
like this
these are aerial images so you can a
need a satellite or a plane to obtain
them and then you need to label them so
all of this is isn't that cheap even
more so in a in a for example medical
domain where you have very expensive CT
images of patients and then you need to
obtain them and you need to convince the
patients to release their data and
someone needs to label it so it's very
costly to obtain lots of training data
now what we want to do is we want to for
all of these tasks we ideally want to
build neural networks deep neural
networks because we know they're super
accurate but they are only super
accurate if you have lots of training
data so that conflicts with the fact
that we might not have so much training
data for these tasks so the proposed
solution here is what's called a visual
task adaptation and it's the following
imagine you have lots and lots of what's
called here upstream data and upstream
data what they mean is data that is
similar to the data here but not exactly
the same but you have lots of it and the
example given is imagenet so imagine
this here to be image net image net
image net is a data set with over a
million images all of them are labeled
into one of a thousand classes and so
you can build a very good model for
image net to predict the image net class
right and you can get very accurate you
have lots of data cool so you built this
model but now what you want to do is you
want to use this what's here called an
adaptation algorithm and you want to use
that model that you trained on imagenet
data and kind of change it just a bit so
you start from the model you have
that works on imagenet and with the few
training data you have here on the right
side and the authors actually
standardized this in the benchmark to 1k
sample so you only have a thousand
training samples you know compared to
the millions that you potentially need
you have a thousand samples and you
adapt your model to these tasks right so
you train the model on imagenet and you
adapt it to predict whether or not
there's a cat or a dog and you adapt it
to segment these images and you adapt it
to predict the depth of points so you
can consider this kind of as a pre
training thing so you pre train your
model on imagenet and then you adapt it
to these others and that's what's called
task adaptation it's not exactly free
training in the classic sense because
pre training the classic sense means
basically that you you you retain the
same model but here it's a bit different
so in stage one right you train a deep
neural network on lots of training data
and a deep neural network here this
might be you know you have a bunch of
layers layer layer layer layer layer and
then here you have a thousand you
classify into a thousand classes all
right this is your model and then in
stage two over here you adopt this model
and what it ultimately means is you take
for example this part here up until the
second-to-last layer transfer it over
put it here right
bam-bam-bam-bam-bam-bam you retain the
weights you keep the weights but then
you add just one or two new layers and
classify your new tasks this could be is
it a cat there is it a dog right and
then you train you can either elect to
only train the green part here or you
can train the whole thing the the second
thing is called a fine-tuning right and
the author is mostly elect to do
fine-tuning in this work so you carry
over the weights and you add a new
and then you train the entire thing with
the 1000 samples that you have for this
task and then you the kind of the goal
is to get as good as possible on that
one tasks where you only have a thousand
samples if you're pre training was good
so if your stage one was good then you
would expect that stage two would profit
a lot from this pre training which
basically means that even though you
only have a thousand samples you can
reach accuracies that would usually only
be possible with much more samples so
that's that the idea behind it right and
this is what's called visual task
adaptation so these the authors propose
a benchmark for this a benchmark for
this part right for the adaptation
algorithm so that the adaptation
algorithm they propose as a baseline is
terrain on imagenet and then fine-tuned
so that's an adaptation algorithm they
propose a score for this so if you come
up with a better adaptation algorithm
for example you could say no I'm going
to whatever train on YouTube data and
then do like fine-tune that and then
maybe you would reach a higher maybe
you'd reach better accuracies in these
tasks over here and then your score
would be higher right so it's kind of a
benchmark to compare adaptation
algorithms so here your benchmark score
and this is conditioned on n the number
of samples that you have in the in the
layer two tasks and this here is
standardized to 1,000 in their case so
the score of an adaptation algorithm a
is the following it's the it's the
expectation over this is kind of an
error measure and you buddy you can you
can think of it basically as a class
tests at classification error on the
layer two tasks
of that adaptation algorithm if given
the dataset of a layer two tasks of n
samples and the layer two tasks here
comes from a distribution of layer two
tasks so what does it mean this this
distribution of layer two tasks they
they imagine and they show this in this
picture they imagine the the visual
tasks like on this on this big landscape
of visual tasks right here and what they
ideally want to do is they want to
sample a task here and this task
correspond to classifying these dog
images and very close to it could be
classifying bird images but then very
far away it could be a task of counting
and depth estimation and so they they
imagine all the visual tasks or have
some kind of some sort of of
distribution right so what happens is
you sample one of those visual tasks or
each for each each element in this
expectation you sample one of them you
build the dataset with a thousand
samples right you put it through your
adaptation algorithm so your adaptation
algorithm for example your pre trained
imagenet you adapt it to to that task
with a thousand samples and then you
compute your error metric on that now if
you do this over the whole distribution
you get an expectation of this error
metric in all the visual tasks and that
will be your score so what is it what
does it mean in practice I mean in
practice you don't have this
distribution right in practice you have
a list
so like list here is a list of tasks
right there's this task this task this
task is sisters whatever the pet's tasks
and then there is the aerial then there
is the counting right you have a list of
tasks and what is it like this stuff and
this expectation ultimately right
Stage one trainer model M
a ch2 for each of these tasks adapt the
model M or fine-tune your model M on
these tasks then for each task get an
error rate error rate 1 task 2 gives you
error rate to task 3 gives you error
rate 3 then Jim simply 1 over n sum them
up so take the take the average error
rate of the of the of all of the tasks
and that's your score it's kind of my
first criticism of this thing like this
this all just seems like super
mathematize with like oh we imagine all
of these tasks being in some
distribution somewhere like that there
is a distribution of tasks and we have
an expectation over the distribution now
like why just say here's a bunch of
tasks right adapt your model to each one
of them get the average error rate done
that's your score that would have been
first of all much easier and second of
all they never actually care to
characterize this distribution like if
if they were to actually rigorously
characterize this distribution of visual
tasks I would agree that this
formulation makes sense but all they say
basically all they say is tasks that a
human can solve from visual input alone
and they give a bunch of examples of
diseases you know a good task would be
the following right da da da da da da da
da da da da so label 1 1 0 0 1 right and
you probably figured it out the task is
is it a square or visited triangle right
that's that's a visual task in the
classic sense human can solve it from
visual input alone then the following
task wouldn't be as easy labels 1 0 0 1
so the task I had in mind was is there
spelling is the spelling of the shape
over here does
contain an a so square contains an a
circle doesn't line doesn't but triangle
contains an a right
so therefore this you kind of need world
knowledge and you can't just solve it
from visual input alone all right
especially not you can't generalize to
new new shapes if you if you just from
visual input so um they and they say
Appendix B they validate this right they
validate that humans can solve it but I
actually disagree with this because just
because humans can solve a task just
from visual input doesn't mean that they
don't use world knowledge in it like in
this whatever pets example here right
humans know how cats and dogs look
anatomically
right how they look from the side and
from the back and so on even if they
haven't seen it in a picture they they
know how they behave and so on what is
kind of realistic setting for a cat and
the dog to be in so all of this it seems
kind of a bit shady and the reason I'm
saying this is if you make this
distribution formulation you also you
have to give a rigorous definition and
because if a new task arrives now like
at one that's not in your list like
never been before here in the world like
new task arrives how do we know whether
or not we should include it in the list
or not right how do we know whether it's
part of this distribution or not it just
seems very very shaky so that being said
they do give this list and this list has
19 tasks that's down here so there are
19 tasks they're categorized as natural
which means natural images these these
yeah the examples here are pets flowers
images house numbers and so on
specialized images or for example images
with that use special equipment for
example medical images and then
structured means where
that's down here structured means that
that the model needs come to comprehend
the structure of a scene so they give an
example of object counting or 3d depth
prediction I mean that's that's fair
enough they they have these 19 tasks but
and they show kind of the tasks down
here here's a list of tasks and kind of
their baseline method on it but but why
for me like the question is why exactly
these tasks like if they don't specify
this distribution why these tasks and
they don't really like they do something
they do a lot of experimentation
actually an investigation but what's
kind of missing for me is to show that
these tasks first of all are kind of
internally consistent in that they're
really visual tasks and second of all
that they kind of cover this
distribution or they represent this
entire distribution that they're trying
to model and it seems to me unclear why
exactly these tasks why they left others
out and include these ones in all
fairness probably they simply took the
ones that that they could get their
hands on but still I feel that this is
very shaky and that might that might
lead to the benchmark not being adapted
very widely but alright enough with the
criticism let's go further in this so
they do present this kind of baseline
experiments and they they pre train
always on imagenet and then they they
fine-tune on these layer two tasks and
the way they pre train here is listed
here for example so if they pre train a
generative model it actually performs
worse than if they just train from
scratch for the layer two tasks on the
thousand samples right self supervise is
kind of a pre training method where if
you have an image you do something like
you rotate it to the right or to the
left and then you ask a model some sort
of a disk
did it did I turn it to the right or to
the left like Al Jazeera was to the
right left and one is to the right so
you this is called self supervise you
don't need labels for this right
and it kind of works well
semi-supervised has some of the labels
and supervised has is like imagenet with
full labels and you kind of see
unsurprisingly that the more information
you have the better you are going to be
in all of these these kind of tasks
interestingly the generative
pre-training works the worst worse than
even from scratch training so that's
kind of a sort of special what what I do
really appreciate about this this
investigation here is that they
investigate a lot of variants of this of
this benchmark and they come to the
conclusion and I think that's
encapsulated here well for example we
find two models using 16 Google cloud
GPU hardware accelerators now that's
expensive right but they say we conduct
additional experiments to assess whether
our result can be reproduced with a more
basic hardware setup we evaluate on all
the tasks using a single Nvidia P 100
GPU with a thousand steps 64 images per
mini batch right so they verified that
you can do this benchmark you can take
part in this benchmark even if you don't
have much time or money or hardware
right that's why for example they limit
they limit the number of examples in the
layer two tasks to a thousand they do
investigate that this correlates with
your performance if you were to include
the full data sets of the layer two
tasks so if you just include a thousand
examples that correlates well they do
investigate they do investigate whether
you can put it on a single GPU they do
investigate if you only run it for a
thousand steps here you see this
experiment you have to run it for a
thousand steps basic
and you're almost at the level if as if
you were to run it for 50,000 steps so
there's a lot of work to that goes into
making sure that everybody can kind of
participate in this benchmark and that I
appreciate this a lot and there is
actually code available so if you go to
github and you just search for task
adaptation actually I had it open before
but I don't know so you go to github and
you go to google research and search for
task adaptation
- and you'll you'll find it there is
code that downloads all of the datasets
for you prepares them and there is a
script that runs your layer 1 model so
you need to provide it a layer 1 model
but then there is a script that that
runs it on all of the different layer 2
tasks and at the end calculates your
benchmark for you so that's really neat
and I would encourage you if you have a
good idea for a pre training or for a
adaptation algorithm take part in the
benchmark I suspect there will be a
leaderboard kind of online leaderboard
coming out at some point otherwise you
were simply can report the number in
your papers and I hope you are going to
be successful at that all right so that
was it for me have lots of fun and bye
bye